Stephen Strange
[Music]
the Illuminati will see you now
see what kind of doctor strange you are
what obvious Doctor Strange
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and we have what looks
to be the most exciting and most
revealing Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness clip yet this clip
right here shows us and tells us through
the narrative a lot we get our very
first look at Professor X's chair our
very first look at Captain Carter
fighting the Scarlet Witch and the suit
that Professor Xavier is going to be
wearing which looks to be pretty dang
identical to the X-Men 97 animated
series and since Captain Carter was in
Marvel's animated series what if it
makes you wonder if these characters are
indeed going to be from animated
universes we'll break everything down
including some things that Professor X
says in this video so if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest MCU videos now for
a small 15 second clip they actually
revealed so much in this scene now it
starts off by Doctor Strange being put
into handcuffs some very very very high
tech handcuffs with the Ultron Bots
behind him we hear a voice saying Steven
strange which is very clearly the voice
of Patrick Stewart which means it is the
voice of Professor Xavier the Ultron
Bots escort Doctor Strange into the
Chamber of the Illuminati their Council
room where they judge people and the
ultrabots actually shove him in we see
Master mordo there as well also backed
up by some Ultron Bots and he says the
Illuminati will see you now so this is
definitely the Judgment room of the
Illuminati we know that by now we've
seen all of the chairs lined up at the
top of it kind of reminds me of Harry
Potter just a little bit on how all the
judges sit on top and they have this
part on the bottom where the accused are
judged now back to this whole entire
scene in just a bit because it's a lot
to break down but first let's talk about
this very brief new Scarlet Witch scene
we're unsure of where she is but it
looks like she has a bunch of demons or
Souls trying to attach to her and what
she just simply throws them away now
she's in her full Scarlet Witch outfit
and I think that this is a full sign of
her true power this is clearly some very
very dark magic that is happening to her
but she simply just brushes it off like
it's nothing she has at least seven of
these beans trying to attach themselves
to her and they do but she just blows
them away and this is important to know
because it leads us into this next scene
in this trailer which is the Illuminati
actually fighting the Scarlet Witch so
going back to the Illuminati we actually
hear when Doctor Strange enters the
chamber Professor X say we will see what
kind of doctor strange you are now these
words actually mean a lot but let's talk
about how epic it is to actually see
Professor Xavier's chair here it is a
yellowish gold hover chair just like
from the X-Men animated series and if
you actually take a look at his sleeve
and some of a suit that's in the frame
it's green just like he was this really
does appear to be the same Professor
Xavier from the Animated Series now it
doesn't mean that he is right now Marvel
Studios has done an excellent job of
giving giving us scenes in movies and in
the Disney Plus shows that are extremely
comic accurate and although the X-Men
animated series isn't a comic it is
something that had a big impact on
Marvel fans and this is extremely
accurate to the Professor Xavier from
that Animated Series so this could
simply be a node to him Marvel Studios
continuing their comic accurate animated
series accurate scenes or it actually
could be him which will be very very
interesting but it wouldn't take us as
that big of a surprise as we do see
Captain Peggy Carter in this TV spot as
well and this kind of really blows my
mind I can't believe that they showed us
this yes they have teased Professor
Xavier before but they had to give us
something as far as cameos but I thought
they would stop there plus they teased
Professor X's chair in this one but no
we get a look at Captain Carter and
although we don't see her face we very
very clearly see her shield now what's
interesting about this scene is that she
is going up against the Scarlet Witch
and though I do love Captain Carter I
think she's an amazing character and I
love Haley Atwell and can't wait to see
her live action I don't think she's any
match for the Scarlet Witch even if she
is actually upgraded if you notice on
her back is a jet pack she actually uses
this to stabilize herself as the Scarlet
Witch pushes her back and this is very
very cool and it definitely gives her an
advantage over no jetpack but still the
Scarlet Witch is now the most powerful
being probably in the entire Multiverse
and Captain Carter is great but she
essentially just has super soldier's
serum and now a jet pack which leads me
to believe based off of all of the
destruction that we've seen in the other
trailers and TV spots that unfortunately
she'll probably die because again I just
think she stands no chance against the
Scarlet Witch and we'll get back to her
Tech in just a second because I do think
this is probably Stark Tech but in this
TV spot we get our most clear look at
who we now know is Maria Rambo as
Captain Marvel this look of her right
here is the most clear look that we've
gotten and there's no mistake now this
is not Superior Iron Man unfortunately
but it is Maria Rambo as a variant of
Captain Marvel now clearly whatever
universe that she came from She's
Captain Marvel and this is pretty easy
to explain as her and Carol Danvers were
both pilots and all you have to do is
swap the stories for Carol and Maria
it's as simple as that instead of Carol
crashing her plane and coming in contact
with the Tesseract it's actually Maria
who does that how does she become
involved with the Illuminati though that
is what I want to know I want to know
how the Illuminati were formed and I
hope they tell us that in Doctor Strange
now in this scene she is clearly going
up to fight against the Scarlet Witch as
well but here's what is kind of
interesting you can see in the
background of Maria Rambo scene and in
the background of Captain Carter scene
that the Scarlet Witch and them fighting
is not actually happening in the
Judgment Chambers that's kind of
happening in like the main room of The
Illuminati's headquarters that big open
room with a glass top the glass top is a
giveaway plus all of the statues that
we've seen in that room as well we see
the glass top and the statues in the
scene with Maria Rambo's Captain Marvel
and when the the Scarlet Witch fights
Peggy Carter so both of these people are
going to be fighting the Scarlet Witch I
hope it's at once because if it's one on
one they're not gonna stand any chance
at all but perhaps they might stand
somewhat of a fight if it's 2V1 now
since this fight is taking place kind of
in that main room I'm wondering if this
attack happens as Doctor Strange is
being judged because remember we've seen
a scene where mordo attacks Doctor
Strange where Doctor Strange is still in
handcuffs and in fact he uses those
handcuffs to block a sword attack from
mordo I'm assuming that at first the
Illuminati probably doesn't know that
doctor strange and Wanda are really at
odds right now they're probably going to
think they're working together so if the
Scarlet Witch starts attacking which I'm
pretty sure is going to happen because
she's just gonna walk in like she owns
the place in which the Illuminati will
tell her to stop and she's not going to
which will therefore cause an attack if
this happens while Doctor Strange is in
the chamber they're going to think that
this is all a part of some plan and
Doctor Strange is about to attack as
well which is where I believe we are
going to get that scene where mordo
attacks Doctor Strange now ultimately I
think we all know this is going to lead
up between a battle between the Scarlet
Witch and the entire Illuminati
including Professor Xavier and rumors
have kind of Gone Wild for Multiverse
Madness but I think we're all kind of
predicting that Professor Xavier is
going to go up against the Scarlet Witch
and probably won't make it in fact if I
had to guess probably none of the
members of the Illuminati are going to
make it out alive as sad as that is
because I'm pretty sure some epic
characters are going to be introduced
but that makes you wonder if it's going
to be on doctor strange after this to
form a new Illuminati or if there simply
won't be an Illuminati anymore now to
finish I want to go back to that jet
pack on the back of Captain Carter I
believe that this is probably Stark Tech
now there have been rumors going around
that Superior Iron Man or any type of
Iron Man might not be in the movie but
even if he's not we have the Ultron Bots
which clearly come from Tony Stark so
even if we don't see him I still imagine
that he played a role in some part
helping the Illuminati giving them the
Ultron Bots and perhaps giving them some
gear to help them Monitor and protect
the universe one of those would probably
be a jet pack for Captain Carter plus
not to mention in the animated what if
storyline Captain Carter was good
friends with Howard Stark and in her
Universe we don't really know what
happened with Howard or Tony perhaps
Howard was never assassinated perhaps he
lived and perhaps he was the Tony Stark
of his time since he never died and he
made some equipment for Captain Carter
to help her out I think that would be
pretty dang cool but this whole 15
second TV spot was amazing I can't
believe they put all of that in just one
quick little clip but it makes me even
more excited for Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness and let me know
how excited you are for the movie and
all of the cameos in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos don't forget to
follow me on Twitter and Instagram for
live updates and as always thank you all
so much for watching woof woof
foreign